culpable Esa fue la decisión Del Jurado
en el caso de Richard Álex murdog un
prestigioso abogado de Carolina del Sur
en Estados Unidos quien asesinó a su
esposa Maggie e hijo Paul en la perrera
de la finca familiar en el condado de
Hampton el 7 de junio de 2021
y Maggie y Paul merecen una voz
necesitan una voz porque ya no pueden
hablar todos los que creían estar cerca
de él todos los que creían saber quién
era los ha engañado a todos y también
engañó a Maggie y Apolo y pagaron por
ello con sus vidas
los dos fueron ejecutados a quemarropa
según Las investigaciones en un inicio
alek había dicho que llegó luego de que
los dos habían muerto y ahí llamó a los
servicios de emergencia pero apareció
una prueba incontestable en el celular
de Paul un video tomado minutos antes
sitúa a su padre en el lugar del crimen
murdog miembro de una familia de
abogados que por generaciones influyó en
el condado de Hampton tenía una adicción
a los opiáceos y perdió credibilidad
ante el Jurado al admitir que había
mentido sobre su coartada y declarar que
había cometido millonarios delitos
financieros al robar a sus socios y
clientes la fiscalía argumentó que el
abogado había asesinado a sus familiares
solo para ganar tiempo antes de intentar
quitarse la vida la defensa argumentaba
que no se llevó a cabo el debido proceso
y que era un padre amoroso incapaz de
cometer los homicidios
porque nunca tomaron pruebas de ADN de
la ropa de Maggie su vestido porque
nunca tomaron muestras del ADN de la
ropa de Paul nunca lo hicieron nunca lo
hicieron
durante décadas hasta 2006 los miembros
de la familia fueron los principales
Fiscales de la zona y poseían influencia
en la policía
burdock se desempeñaba como abogado de
lesiones personales en el estado con El
veredicto de culpabilidad Álex se
enfrenta hasta a cadena perpetua en la
sentencia